monsieur vous aurez alors député pensez
vous que la politique et le rire peut
faire bon ménage
je crois que ça fait souvent bon ménage
on a une vision peut-être un peu trop
triste de la politique peut-on
caricatural et on risque plutôt pas mal
dans ce métier autant que dans un autre
mais vous savez vous réunissez des
hommes et des femmes ensemble dans un
endroit peu confiné
ils ont des besoins de collégiens qui
viennent de spontanément à la bouche et
on n'échappe à donc la plaisanterie
quelquefois graveleux quelquefois plus
fine argent les députés en séance se
disputent quelques fois est-ce qui vous
prendre ça au sérieux ou sanou partie du
spectacle
il ya beaucoup de spectacle d'ailleurs
c'est pas très satisfaisant de voir des
gens dits s'échappe comme ça en public
qui se réconcilient houle où s'échangent
des bonnes plaisanterie en privé
faudrait peut-être être plus drôle en
public et peut-être plus argumentée même
plus ce sont les communes qui qui vous
font beaucoup rire
écoutez moi j'étais dans le même lycée
que clavier jugnot donc j'ai gardé et
finalement une fidélité à ce comité là
je suis caf était aussi brûlé est-ce que
vous pensez que ça marc raynaud afin
d'apport à l'histoire du rire en france
oui je crois qu'il a rétabli le mime se
faire dorer nos le moi j'ai toujours
gardé en mémoire parce que d'abord j'ai
été
et ensuite je vois maintenant défilé des
militants le sketch défilé plus je
trouve représentatif de toute une
société qui n'évoluent pas mais je la
vois se reproduire sous mes yeux à
chaque 14 juillet donc je remercie
fernand raynaud tous les 14 juillet
parce que vous êtes un homme qui raconte
des histoires à table non japon pas des
histoires à proprement parler c'est à
dire des histoires a prises
j'essaye de raconter l'histoire qui me
sont arrivées et je trouve que la
réalité même sur la racontent souvent
mal aulas travesti permet de beaucoup
plus rire que la fiction dans le travail
du député il ya plein d'histoires drôles
compte qu'on capte comme ça histoire qui
nous arrive le même
merci à gâteau